freunde der sonne grüße aus den rocky
mountains ungewohnte location aber dafür
ein umso vertrautes thema das garantiert
jeder von euch in irgendeiner art und
weise kennt nämlich dinge die uns allen
gehören bzw die für uns alle da sind
werden meistens scheiße behandelt was
meine ich damit ja zum beispiel ist mir
beim wanderer aufgefallen egal wie
idyllisch es irgendwo ist egal wie schön
all die schönheit hat ein ende und zwar
hier sind immer ekelhaft niemand wickelt
bei sich zu hause auf dem boden und
trotzdem ist es quasi ein physikalisches
gesetz dass der boden von öffentlichen
toiletten folge pinkelt ist oder niemand
weiß was ich zu hause müllen den garten
und trotzdem ist es praktisch
unvermeidbar dass öffentliche gelände
nach einem festival oder ähnlichen sich
in große müllhalden verwandeln warum ist
das so was halt immer egoistischer
arschlöcher gibt die alles kaputt machen
könnte man jetzt sagen nun ganz so
einfach ist es nicht warum wir an
öffentlichen toiletten oder festival
geländen scheitern ist eine wissenschaft
für sich und diese wissenschaft unseres
scheiterns die schauen wir uns jetzt
etwas genauer an
[Musik]
ja das problem ist wahrscheinlich so alt
wie die menschheit selbst und hat seit
rund 200 jahren auch einen namen nämlich
tragedy of the comments oder tragödie
des gemeingut gemeingut ist etwas das
uns allen gehört beziehungsweise dass
wir uns alle da ist das wir alle teilen
das können öffentliche toiletten seien
öffentliche gelände im kleinen kann das
aber auch die geteilte wg küche seien im
großen die sauberkeit unserer ozeane
oder das globale klima und überall wo
wir ins güter teilen tragödien denn wo
güter geteilt werden gibt es auch immer
menschen die das knallhart ausnutzen
die nichts zum allgemeinwohl beitragen
aber trotzdem davon profitieren das hat
natürlich was damit zu tun dass die
menschen egoistisch handeln aber das
problem ist noch viel vielschichtiger
ist dass es ist wie gesagt eine
wissenschaft die vor allem von
wirtschaftswissenschaftlern und
psychologen intensiv erforscht wird
unter anderem im labor unser
menschliches sozialverhalten lässt sich
nämlich experimentell abbilden indem man
menschen spiele spielen lässt jetzt wird
spannt ein experiment das die tragödie
das gemeingut sehr gut abbildet ist das
öffentliche güter spiel sagen wir du
spielst zusammen mit noch drei weiteren
spielern jeder von euch spielt anonym
zum beispiel über einen computer
jede spielrunde bekommt jeder einen euro
diesen euro kann man entweder für sich
behalten oder man kann ihn in den
öffentlichen topf werfen denn alles was
in den öffentlichen topf kommt wird
verdoppelt und anschließend durch vier
geteilt und gleichmäßig in alle wieder
ausgezahlt
solange irgendjemand was in diesen
öffentlichen topf wirft geht das spiel
weiter in die nächste runde wo dann
wieder jeder euro bekommt sagen wir
jeder von euch vielen gibt sein euro in
den öffentlichen topf es ganz wird
verdoppelt auf acht euro
und so kriegt jeder von euch zwei euro
wieder zurück so gewinnt jeder
mitspieler diese runde 1 euro gemeingut
verlangt immer kooperation
zusammenarbeit ich muss jetzt für das
allgemeinwohl immer irgendwas aufbringen
sei es jetzt zeit mühe verzicht geld
diesem fall jetzt in euro aber wenn alle
beitragen haben auch alle was davon wenn
alle zusammenarbeiten profitiert jeder
bin jeder jede runde sein euro rein gibt
können alle ewig weiterspielen und so
unendlich reich werden
das ist langfristig natürlich das best
case szenario was für alle am besten ist
ist langfristig auch für den einzelnen
am besten diese spielregel gilt auch oft
im echten leben für geteilte güte das wg
geschirr zu spülen das immer noch besser
als am ende in einer verdreckten küche
zu leben in der es für niemanden mehr
sauberes geschirr gibt auf die flugreise
zu verzichten ist am ende immer noch
besser als die folgen des klimawandels
weniger zu fischen ist am ende immer
noch besser als ein eher gemischtes
gewässer in dem dann niemanden erwischen
können weil die population langfristig
eingebrochen ist also noch mal was für
alle am besten ist es langfristig auch
für den einzelnen am besten doch leider
sind diese spielregeln auch so gestaltet
dass egoistisches verhalten kurzfristig
belohnt wird das soziale dilemma sagen
wir du legst dein euro in den
öffentlichen topf bekommst aber nur 1
euro 50 zurück dann weißt du ein
mitspieler hat egoistisch gespielt und
seien euro für sich behalten nur drei
mitspieler haben ihren euro in den
öffentlichen topf gegeben
die wurden dann auf sechs euro
verdoppelt und
gleichmäßig in alle vier ausgezahlt also
150 für jeden wird zwar immer noch 50
cent gewinn gemacht aber der a steht den
euro für sich behalten hat hat natürlich
ein auge 50 gewinn gemacht nur was heißt
er nicht bei diesem öffentlichen güter
spiel rein wirtschaftlich denke dann ist
das kurzfristig immer besser den euro
für sich zu behalten denn nicht nur
bekomme ich so definitiv mehr geld raus
sondern ich vermeide so gehört das
risiko vielleicht der einzig blute zu
sein der seinen euro in den öffentlichen
topf gibt und dann auch noch verlust
macht die spielregeln erschaffen also
ein sogenanntes soziales dilemma
soziales dilemma heißt das sind diese
moment am besten für mich ist ist nicht
das was am besten für das gemeinwohl ist
und diesem moment ist es für mich am
besten ins flugzeug zu steigen und einen
schönen urlaub zu haben in diesem moment
ist es für mich am besten den geschirr
berg in der wg-küche zu ignorieren in
diesem moment ist es für mich am besten
den euro zu behalten es ist also nur
nachvollziehbar dass menschen dieses
spiel so spielen dass sie gewinnen nur
der gewinn ist nicht von dauer
ich bin doch nicht der einzige blöde
sobald er feststeht dass dein mitspieler
sein euro für sich behalten hat denkst
du dir natürlich ich bin noch nicht so
blöd und spendet mein euro für das
allgemeinwohl während irgendwelche
schmarotzer nichts machen und behält
sein euro die nächste runde für dich
dieser gedanke ich bin noch nicht der
einzige blöde spielt auch eine große
rolle bei themen wie umweltschutz wieso
sollte ich meinen alten diesel stehen
lassen wären die amis in ihren suvs die
luft verpesten wieso sollte ich
plastikmüll reduzieren während in china
der müll in die flüsse gekippt wird aber
auch sachen wie wieso sollte ich
pünktlich zum gruppen meeting kommen
wenn ich doch dann eh wieder auf die
typischen zuspätkommer warten muss
zurück zum spiel falls du jetzt immer
noch einer das gemeinwohl glaubst und
ein euro doch nicht für dich bist da
macht es hat jemand anderes aus der
runde ziemlich sicher und dann sind wir
auch schon an den punkt an dem das spiel
scheitert so bald nur noch zwei spieler
ihren euro in den öffentlichen topf
geben machen diese beiden spender gar
keinen gewinn mehr während die beiden
egoisten dazugewinnen und spätestens
dann denken sich die spender [ __ ] you
keiner geht es mehr bock was in den
öffentlichen topf zu geben das spiel
bricht zusammen keiner kann jetzt mehr
gewinnen alle sind gescheitert
das ist die tragödie des gemeingut unser
beispiel ist jetzt eine sehr einfache
variante des öffentliche güter spielt
man kann dieses spiel natürlich auch mit
viel mehr spielern spielen dann kann
auch die regeln etwas komplexer
gestalten zum beispiel
in dem die leute nicht ihren ganzen euro
raum geben müssen sondern entscheiden
können welchen teil davon sie rein geben
zum beispiel 30 cent oder 70 cent
doch wie auch immer mal dieses spiel
spielt und egal mit wem und egal wo also
egal in welcher kultur das öffentliche
güter spielen ist zum scheitern
verurteilt aus wissenschaftlicher sicht
ist die tragödie des gemeinwohls wird
ziemlich sichere kiste das heißt wenn
mal wieder öffentliche güter scheiße
behandelt werden gibt es eigentlich
überhaupt kein grund zur überraschung
oder entrüstung
es kam halt mal wieder wie es kommen
musste aber zum glück heißt das nicht
dass wir jetzt machtlos zuschauen müssen
wie wir jetzt alle gemeinsam güter
zerstören das sind die spielregeln die
zum scheitern führen dass soziale
dilemma so lange die schwierigen so
gemacht sind das die egoistische
entscheidung kurzfristig den größten
gewinn oder den geringsten verlust
bringt wird die tragödie des gemeingut
eintreten
früher oder später so lange kurzflüge
billiger sind als bahn fahrten wird sich
die umweltfreundliche variante nicht
durchsetzen
zweitens anonymität in unserem
öffentlichen güter spiel sitzen die vier
spieler ja nicht gemeinsam einem tisch
sondern das spiel ist anonymisiert
außerdem können die spieler nicht
miteinander kommunizieren
man hat also kein einfluss auf das
verhalten oder die entscheidung der
anderen deswegen ist es noch ziemlich
einfach eine de toilette sauber zu
halten
aber bei einer öffentlichen toilette
kann niemand mehr nachvollziehen wer
welche sauerei hinterlässt und derjenige
der die sauerei hinterlässt trägt auch
nicht die konsequenzen und entsprechend
sehen die toiletten danach aus das heißt
aber auch dass wir kooperation fördern
können wenn wir die spielregeln ändern
wir können versuchen die tragödie zu
durchbrechen und genau das versuchen
auch forscher im labor in experimenten
mit dem ziel gute spielregeln finden es
gibt verschiedene möglichkeiten in einem
öffentliche güter spiel die kooperation
zu stärken
zum beispiel kann man die egoistische
entscheidung weniger belohnen oder sogar
bestrafen geldstrafen zum beispiel
können ziemlich effektiv eingesetzt
werden wird im bereich umweltschutz zum
beispiel heißt das dass wir
umweltfreundliche produkte oder
dienstleistungen subventionieren können
und dafür dann kerosin ordentlich
besteuern können damit fliegen teurer
wird
doch besonders
dann finde ich maßnahmen oder
spielregeln die unser grund menschliches
soziales verhalten geschickt ausnutzen
denn dass wir menschen anderen menschen
helfen wollen ist mehr als nur
gutmenschentum reziprozität anders
gesagt wie du mir so ich dir mein
kooperatives behalten heute kann mir in
zukunft vorteile bringen und mein
egoistisches warten heute könnte mich in
zukunft bestrafen besonders deutlich
wird das wenn das öffentliche güter
spiel mit nur zwei teilnehmer gespielt
wird prisoners dilemma oder gefangenen
dilemma heißt es dann man kann es wie so
spielen dass der spielpartner jede runde
gewechselt wird es aber eine
wahrscheinlichkeit gibt auf jemanden ein
zweites mal zu treffen und je höher die
chance ist auf diese wiederbegegnung
desto besser kooperieren die leute klar
denn wenn ich jemanden eimer ausnutze
dann kriege ich das beim zweiten mal
garantiert zurück doch selbst wenn man
niemals auf denselben spielpartner
wiedertrifft gibt es trotzdem noch
soziale anreize zur kooperation im
direkte reziprozität wenn ich einen
menschen helfe und andere bekommt das
mit dann sind die auch eher dazu bereit
mir zu helfen hier geht es also um
persönliche standing um den ruf um die
reputation beim gefangenen dilemma
beobachtet man eine erhöhte kooperation
denn man den spielern vor jeder runde
mitteilt wie die anderen jeweils bisher
gespielt haben
und wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel sehr oft
mein euro für mich behalten habe habe
ich eine schlechte reputation und die
anderen haben keinen grund mir zutrauen
eine gute reputation hingegen wird mit
kooperation belohnt und das funktioniert
nicht nur im labor nehme mein beispiel
hier aus den usa fast jedes haus hier
hat eine klimaanlage selbst dieses teil
nie aus
wenn es im sommer jetzt sehr heiß wird
und alle volle kanne ihr team anlage
aufdrehen kann es im ernstfall zu einem
blackout also zu einem stromausfall
kommen und dann sitzen dahlewitz
klassisches gemeingut problem also warum
sollte ich jetzt meine klimaanlage
ausmachen und schwitzen um einem
stromausfall vorzubeugen während bei
nachbar im kühlen sitzt in dieser
amerikanischen studie wurde die
bereitschaft von anwohnern untersucht
bei einem blackout prevention program
mitzumachen also bei einem stromausfall
vermeidungs programm ist das programm
funktioniert so man erklärt sich dazu
bereit das in zeiten von besonders hohem
stromverbrauch der stromanbieter per
fernbedienung bestimmte geräte in meinem
haushalt ausschalten darf damit eben
nicht das ganze netz zusammenbricht die
studie fand eine dreifach erhöhte
bereitschaft bei diesem programm
mitzumachen denn die namen der held nach
ein stromsparer öffentlich sichtbar war
stadt an um ein finanzielles dankeschön
von 25 dollar hatte hingegen fast keinen
effekt das heißt soziale belohnung
funktioniert hier besser als finanzielle
spannt oder man findet sogar immer
wieder heraus dass eine finanzielle
belohnung nach hinten losgehen kann also
für das beispiel strom sparen muss man
sich das so vorstellen
ich mache jetzt bei diesem programm mit
seil ich für das allgemeinwohl bin
vielleicht ein blackout verhindern
möchte das stärkt meine reputation
wenn ich jetzt dafür aber geld bekomme
doch mache ich das vielleicht nur fürs
geld und das schwächt meine reputation
jedenfalls durch reputations förderung
und durch reziprozität also durch
gegenseitigkeit wird kollaboration auch
für egoisten attraktiv hilfsbereit sein
und zusammen arbeiten kann ein
knallharter individuell der vorteil sei
die forschung zu diesem thema ist
unglaublich breit und sehr spannend
dieses video bietet jetzt nur einen
kleinen einstieg in das thema aber für
mehr infos zum einen die video
beschreibung klar ist aber dass geteilte
güter nicht in tragödien enden müssen
man kann mit den richtigen
rahmenbedingungen mit den richtigen
spielregeln dafür sorgen dass menschen
besser zusammenarbeit und auch wenn wir
noch sehr oft scheitern die menschen
sind immerhin schlau genug um uns selbst
auf zu setzen sei es der wg putzplan
oder unser grundgesetz um uns eben vor
der zerstörerischen kraft und seine
eigenen interessen zu schützen das coole
an diesem thema ist wenn man sich einmal
mit der tragödie des gemeinwohls
beschäftigt hat
diese tragödie überall im alltag und ich
bin mir sicher ihr findet auch eure
eigenen beispiele sei es ihm in der wg
oder bei einem gemeinsamen schule oder
uni projekt wo man zusammen arbeitet und
gemeinsam benotet wird oder sogar im
familienalltag deswegen schreibt eure
persönlichen tragödien des gemeinwohls
in die kommentare
vielleicht sind ja auch beispiele dabei
wo es richtig gut funktioniert und wenn
also ist dann schreibt bitte auch warum
er das so gut hinkriegt ich bin die
nächsten wochen hier in den usa
unterwegs das bedeutet auch ich habe für
meinen urlaub zwei fernflüge auf dem
gewissen
damit bin ich ein sehr schlechtes
beispiel beziehungsweise ein gutes
schlechtes beispiel für die tragödie
unseres klimas das ist jetzt nicht das
beste thema für so eine ent card weil
man dazu sicherlich ein ganzes video
machen könnte aber ich habe euch in der
video beschreibung ein paar infos zu dem
konzept co2 kompensation verlinkt das
heißt man zahlt eine spende oder strafe
dafür dass der co2 ausstoß des fluges
anderweitig kompensiert wird
ich habe meine flüge kompensiert weil
ich nun mal geflogen bin und ich denke
des spenders besser als keine und weil
ich eigentlich auch finde wer sich eine
fernreise leisten kann muss sich auch so
eine klima strafe leisten können aber es
gibt zu diesem konzept einiges an
berechtigter kritik die ich auch nur zu
nachvollziehen kann
und weil das thema sehr gut zu treasury
auf der commons passt würde ich gerne
hier mit auch diese diskussion in den
kommentaren anstoßen habt ihr mit dem
thema co2 kompensation erfahrung oder ob
die gedanken dazu vielleicht ergibt sich
ja mit eurem input ein guter start für
tatsächlich ein ganzes video zu dem
thema ich werde mich jedenfalls jetzt im
urlaub weiterhin inspirieren lassen für
neue video ideen aber sieht es bei nach
dass man upload ein wenig unregelmäßiger
sein wird aber wir sehen uns definitiv
bald und bis dahin bleibt sicher